bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france vous avez retiré
votre candidature jean serge bokassa
mais la cour constitutionnelle a
invalidé votre demande de retrait demain
vous n'irez pas voter c'est ce que vous
affirmez pour quelles raisons tout
simplement parce que je ne veux pas
cautionner ce que je considère comme
étant une mascarade électorale qui pis
est exposé la vie de nos concitoyens à
des risques évidents
je pense que les informations que vous
avez telles que je les ai écoutés telles
que je les ai vus dans votre journal ne
présente une situation par ses nerfs de
la réalité sécuritaire qu'il est en
république centrafricaine
il ya de nombreuses régions aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont occupés par des groupes
armés et nos concitoyens seront tout
simplement dans l'impossibilité d'aller
voter
donc outre le fait qu'il ya eu un grand
nombre d'irrégularités qui ont été donc
relever mais pour lesquels aucune suite
n'a été donnée
il ya aujourd'hui cette donne
sécuritaire qui me semble être
extrêmement importante dès qu'ils ne
peut pas permettre qu'une élection se
tienne
donc de ce fait là je ne souhaite pas
cautionner cela
c'est une forme de parts ou parodie
électorale de parodie d'élection qui je
pense renferme
d'entrée de jeu les germes des futures
conclut que nous allons connaître
pourtant donné pourtant en 2016 la
situation elle n'était pas si ces
différentes aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
quand même préciser c'est que les forces
onusiennes affirme que la situation
allait sous contrôle même si vous l'avez
dit c'est vrai il ya des groupes armés
qui sont actifs quand même à l'intérieur
du pays quelle est la différence avec la
avec 2016 à l'époque aussi on sortait
d'une transition l'élection s'est tenue
tout de même dans des conditions
compliquées aussi s'écrire sur le plan
sécuritaire écoutez c'est à dire que la
situation était complètement différente
de celle de 2015 2016
il y avait d'abord premièrement il y
avait moins de groupes armés sur le
territoire
donc c'est quand même assez surprenant
que durant les cinq années de mandat de
monsieur faustin archange touadéra il ya
eu une prolifération de ces groupes
armés à nous sommes passés de près de 4
à 5 groupes
né à 14 me permet aujourd'hui c'est
assez surprenant c'est le premier point
le second point c'est que pendant les
élections de 2015 2016
il y avait une trêve qui est observé par
les concernés aucun groupe armé leucémie
au travers du processus électoral ce qui
me semble être une bonne extrêmement
importante
j'en viens maintenant plan de
sécurisation du processus électoral
moi qui fus critiques étaient candidats
qui ne suffit manifestement toujours
suite à la décision de la cour
constitutionnelle
je n'ai pas eu un seul élément de
sécurité durant tout ce durant toute la
campagne
alors vous voyez bien qu'il ya des
disparités qui sont évidentes des
traitements qui sont évidents un outil
de réalité totalement différentes la
réalité du camp qui est au pouvoir qui
jouit des privilèges liés justement à
vos responsabilités qu'ils occupent
aujourd'hui au sommet de l'état et la
réalité d'un peuple qui est totalement
abandonnée mais moi je peux parler pour
ce peuple abandonné et je veux
m'identifier à ce peuple abandonné là je
fais acte de solidarité vis-à-vis de ces
l'ex-ministre de la sécurité de l'actuel
président justement sur le plan
sécuritaire il ya des groupes armés qui
sont ces groupes armés qui que les
contrôles qui est à la manette c'est
vous dire parce qu'on a accusé aussi
l'ex chef de l'état françois bozizé
d'avoir tenté un coup d'état dans votre
pays et on sait que vous l'avez soutenu
françois bozizé aussi on le précise
avant sa chute
oui mais écoutez je pense que il faut
faut arrêter de je pense de se voiler la
face le président faustin archange
touadéra quand il parle de sa politique
de la main tendue à qui il tend la main
et hakima tant pis lama durant cinq ans
si ce n'est à ces chefs de groupes armés
qui aujourd'hui se retourne contre lui
alors la question c'est à lui qu'il faut
la poser qui sont ces six responsables
de quoi la question que l'on peut poser
c'est pourquoi ces groupes armés se
retourne contre lui aujourd'hui alors
qu'ils ont signé ces groupes
un accord l'accord de cartons non sens
bien en 2019
la formation que je que je dirige
aujourd'hui s'est toujours érigé contre
les accords de khartoum qui consacrait
qui consacre d'ailleurs toujours une
actualité totale à ces groupes armés la
voilà les résultats aujourd'hui de cet
accord de khartoum
nous en voyons ici toutes les
insuffisances voilà les résultats de la
politique de la main tendue du président
faustin archange touadéra qui en cinq
ans manifestement n'a pas pu rapporter
la paix alors que c'est ce que le centre
africain de banques prioritairement
alors je vois pas ce qu'il va apporter
d'autres avant cinq années
supplémentaires
je dis tout simplement dit vous n'avez
pas répondu concernant la halle et
l'éventuelle responsabilité de françois
bozizé qui menait une coalition de
l'opposition la coalition à cod 2020 tu
m'aimais pardon il menait une coalition
il était le chef d'une coalition de
l'opposition cod 2020 montant de lanvin
sur leurs positions le code le cot va je
n'en fais pas partie madame mouvement
n'en fait pas partie nous n'avons jamais
souscrit à intégrer ou côte va j'ai
toujours essayé de défendre des idées
qui sont les miennes avec les
convictions qui sont les miennes il se
trompe en grève ils étaient de françois
bozizé com quelle est votre position là
dessus mais écoutez la responsabilité de
françois bozizé reste la responsabilité
de françois bozizé si aujourd'hui nous
estime le chemin qu'il en sait le chemin
qui est consacrée à marie président
faustin archange touadéra c'est le
chemin qui est consacrée éventuellement
par ceux qui sont censés représenter la
communauté internationale de notre pays
c'est aujourd'hui voilà voilà l'école
qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
apprend à respecter les chefs de groupes
armés n'est pas les citoyens qui
aujourd'hui sont en quête de paix c'est
la triste réalité de notre pays
donc je ne suis pas moi personnellement
je ne porte aucune caution à ceux à ce
type d'approché l'a d'ailleurs je je
j'ai toujours été un fervent défenseur
des valeurs démocratiques dans mon pays
un jeu reste un pacifiste engagé 1 je
condamne d'ailleurs les tout ce qui va
dans le sens d'une prise de pouvoir par
la force dans mon pays mais de grâce ne
vous inquiétez pas des responsabilités
sur des sujets aujourd'hui dont on est
complètement ignorant ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont sur la prédominance à
la prédominance des groupes armés
puisque vous avez été vous même ministre
de la sécurité
aujourd'hui il ya une conférence
virtuelle de la cie
asselah la communauté économique des
états de l'afrique centrale qui demande
aussi la levée de l'embargo sur les
armes
concernant la centrafrique c'est un
texte que la france a soutenues à l'onu
il ya eu une abstention lors du vote de
la chine et de la russie sur ce texte
est-ce que la levée de cet embargo
pourrait justement permettre à l'armée
de mieux se professionnalise et de
pouvoir de créer une armée pérenne face
justement à la situation sécuritaire
inquiétante dans votre pays
je pense qu'il faut non seulement la
levée de l'embargo je suis un patriote
vous savez j'aime mon pays et je pense
important de restaurer ils mentent les
institutions et les missions qui sont
censés les soutenir comme celle de
l'armée nationale c'est extrêmement
important maintenant je pense également
que la langue
l'embargo vous allez aujourd'hui
permettre à notre armée nationale d'être
en condition de pouvoir mener ses
missions mais lorsqu'on tient compte des
accords de khartoum qui aujourd'hui
permettent vous foncent en sorte que nos
forces d'armes armées centrafricaines
son temps à faire des missions
conjointes avec justement des rebelles
pour soi-disant pacifié notre territoire
alors comment voulez-vous consignes et
cela c'est inconciliables je pense que
l'embargo il faut lever mais avec un
gouvernement responsable et une
orientation politique totalement
différente si mon point de vue hélas
hélas c'est qu'ils envisageraient aussi
de deux d'envoyer des troupes en
centrafrique on sait que parmi ses
membres il ya quand même des pays qui se
sont concernés par la situation de votre
pays on peut citer par exemple congo k
est un ancien médiateur mais aussi le
tchad voisin qui a une frontière sud
avec la république centrafricaine est ce
que vous souhaitez vous que l'intéressé
bouge
justement à l'homme mois je souhaiterais
premièrement aujourd'hui qu'on permette
aux centrafricains de discuter avec eux
mêmes et de d'arrivée eux mêmes à
trouver les solutions les plus
appropriées pour leur pays on a été
assisté par plusieurs groupes par
plusieurs armée multinationale
ils sont d'ailleurs en grand nombre sur
notre territoire ça ne change absolument
rien la politique de la main tendue du
président de la république nasnas
changer absolument rien il faut première
en comptant le soir je pense aux
centrafricains de se retrouver
véritablement avec eux-mêmes et de
définir ce qui aujourd'hui peut
contribuer à ramener la paix dans leur
pays
un des locataires centrafricain s'impose
s'impose véritablement nous faut des
solutions politiques et ensuite
envisager pourquoi pas des solutions qui
peuvent être entre guillemets on va dire
militaire est-ce que jusqu'ici la
solution militaire n'a pas apporté grand
chose on a un problème de justice madame
dans ce pays un problème de justice il
faut arrêter de consacrer l'impunité
je pense que si la solution n'est pas
forcément militaire et peut-être
policière et elle doit être judiciaire
aujourd'hui je pense que le désert qui
s'est installée dans notre pays relève
uniquement du rétablissement de l'ordre
de l'ordre public et de son maintien
maintien de la paix on n'a pas besoin
forcément d'avoir décidé d'aider des
forces armées impressionnante dans notre
pays c'est du grand banditisme qui s'est
installée dans notre pays et qui s'est
finalement structurés merci à vous jean
serge bokassa je rappelle que vous avez
retiré votre candidature pour cette
présidentielle et vous êtes l'un des
fils de l'ancien empereur jean-bedel
bokassa merci à vous